tia i mua
tu as fait l'opéra du rhin tu as fait
les arts déco de strasbourg tu fais de
la mode bien évidemment émanant de la
photo ça va te falloir une interview
pinceau très bien
[Applaudissements]
et
la mode qu'est ce que tu as inventé est
à inventer les épaules fois les épaules
mugler c'est un truc très important je
crois que j'ai aussi inventé le corps
wen h du corps un sens oui dans ce qui
restera tu crois pas que les épaules
retour un quasi no6 way
depuis pâques avant de commencer ma
maison thierry mugler j'avais monté une
maison que j'avais prénommé café de
paris oui et ça c'était en plein raout
du folklore enfin les rôles variés
autour de paris paul mugler ça restera
un peu comme le symbole des années 80
quand même alors tu as inventé une femme
un peu comme ça hiératique un peu
inaccessible en dit toi que tu préfères
la femme aux femmes est ce que c'est
vrai c'est vrai que si tu dis ça c'est
que tu penses la femme idéale à une
femme assez bien roulé c'est un peu vrai
tu vas voir comment maintenant la
parisienne des années 90 je la vois
asséner s'entassent énergie classe et un
rythme et tu es un peu le symbole du
créateur dans la mode sur l'appel de
créateurs est ce que tu crois pas que
dans le dans les années 80
on a un peu trop divinisé le chiffon
comme ça est ce que le créateur avait
été mis sur un piédestal un peu un peu
trop finalement puisque la meute s'est
rhabillé les gens quoi un peu d'accord
avec toi non seulement la divinisé mais
on a un petit peu pensé merveille on l'a
donné l'état facilité on a donné des
priorités concours
et puis ça s'est un petit peu aussi
géographiquement dispersés et ça c'est
un peu dommage parce que
y a pas trente six mille endroits où la
botte se fait bien il ya paris c'est sûr
la petite italie enfin bon et voilà tant
que je crois qu'avant tout on habille le
la feuille blanche d'un créateur de mode
c'est le corps humain et puis on a vu
des corps humain il faut essayer de les
rendre plus gros et mieux
il ya une espèce de meute de la mode est
ce que tu crois pas qu'on en est qu'on
en est au bout je crois qu'il ya plus de
modes de la mort de randonnée en ce
moment et creux de la vague est dégoûté
de la mode
en plus des stands à toi j'espère n'ont
pas moins puisque moi je m'attache
justement une espèce de de nouveau
classicisme deux espèces de juste de
ligne ou parce que j'essaye de faire
quand tu fais des photos et un bouquin
qui vient de sortir aux éditions du
regard qui est très très beau ne pas
être facile à monter ses photos quand
même parce que pour faire monter tous
ses mannequins en semaine une immense de
police fait mal non seulement y aller
seul mais des monuments il ya les
conditions atmosphériques pas si c'est
sur les endroits très difficile car les
autorisations parce que certaines de ces
photos représentent des prouesses
diplomatiques sont importantes ou la
volvo grade compris ça j'arrive en bas
beaucoup aidé pour ça mon repos craint
justement il en livrant plus appris
c'est un record pour arriver à voir ces
autorisations du rsa et puis c'est des
photos qui sont faites comme un peu un
tournage de film on sait qu'ils sont
très préparés parce quand on est au bord
du vide 60e étage on peut pas tout soit
vraiment précis alors entre proches un
peu dans ses photos des fois un certain
mussolinisme certains jeux ratés comme
je les invite et photos oui je te vois
qu'avant ça ce trouve pas qu'il ya un
côté comme ça un peu leni riefenstahl si
quand même non moi je vois pas de mal à
sa voiture parce que les lire un peu de
style c'était quelqu'un qui avait
beaucoup de talent que évidemment
on s'est empressé d'utiliser parce que à
l'époque on chercher les meilleurs
talents pour promouvoir certaines idées
et puis c'est souvent comme ça quand les
gens ont des choses à dire bien ou mal
ils vont évidemment s'entourer des
meilleurs donc sauf que les avais tu
t'en vas tout alain bon tu sais si tu
étais pas thierry mugler à l'aventurier
a été influencé par qui j'étais
influencé par leni riefenstahl j'ai
préparé mes répondu tant pis tout on
nous fait référence donc je dis ce que
je pense
j'étais influencé par
polygone et ça c'est sûr le photographe
s'était influencé beaucoup par défaut
les pattes et fo ça c'est une chose qui
est toujours très proche de moi parce
que rythme et une violence et est
quelque chose qui est plus que l'humain
explique instant que j'aime beaucoup et
toujours
et puis la musique
justement tu écoutes quoi quand tu
travailles j'écoute beaucoup d vite à
l'état pur si tu veux des choses assez
brut comme trinidad comme le tam-tam
afrique choses comme ça tu vois un truc
un peu plus mais combien de temps pour
dessiner un modèle très vite c'est à
dire non je peux pas dire que je suis
une fille de papier blanc comme ça je te
demande d'aidé sinon c'est bon c'est
bien c'est rentable dit l'on me dit tu
sais on a vu par les gens avec une
feuille de papier une réponse été copié
par kima exemple par qui balance
beaucoup
tu penses à la fin je viens apporter
quoi la main à la sortie je crois que
j'allais résumé avoir et avait suiveurs
j'ai apporté je pense une liberté dans
la coupe et une modernité dans la coupe
et veut dire qu'on peut très bien faire
une culture qui prend la forme d'une
poupée est ce qu'on peut faire une poche
qui a la forme une orange et tout ça
c'est moi qui la porte est
indéniablement je peux pas je veux pas
dire que j'ai c'est très très important
journal beaucoup mais une chose dont je
suis sûr c'est ça tu vois comment à 55
ans superbe